what are Stakes
something that confuses a lot of a lot
of writers it's um so
Stakes are very generally like whatever
hangs in the balance
um with regard to what your character is
trying to achieve so a lot of movies are
very clear external you know life and
death Stakes right if your character
doesn't
um escape the serial killer then they
will die right the your protagonist will
die so that it's life and death Stakes
um so it's whatever consequence would
would come and would come to Bear if
your protagonist fails to achieve their
story goal that's sort of how I would
define it
why are Stakes important uh well I think
Stakes are important because that's
if if there's nothing at stake then the
story doesn't matter right if um if your
protagonist is trying to achieve a thing
but nothing there won't be any
consequence to it then
I don't know if your audience will
remain engaged in the story right
because we we sort of if we if we
understand that a series of events
doesn't matter it doesn't have any
consequence to it it's inconsequential I
think most of us would check out could
be entertaining for a while but
eventually we'll be like okay I you know
I don't really care about the ending of
it so whatever's at stake in the story
is really what sort of gets us to care
about the outcome
yeah and I know again we use hustle as
an example and I think that's what got
the film for me that's why I liked it
I'm not really into sports but the the
stakes that were involved and it was
numerous times yeah that was what was so
great is you thought you got through one
hurdle and then there was another one
presented yeah and I think you know all
of these elements sort of go hand in
hand right they all depend on each other
to kind of create the effect that you
want them to create on the audience so
what's great about hustle is like it
it's not life or death Stakes it's not
that you know high stakes of a of a
movie but you feel so much for that
character that what's important to him
is important to you so that you know
what this career means to him it's the
only thing he's ever done it's what he
loves it's you know what he's dedicated
his whole life to there's the feeling
that if he sort of washes out now his
whole life will be meaningless or you
know he'll have invested all this time
and something that ultimately didn't
matter had no out no uh consequence so
all all of that is wrapped up in what's
at stake for him so
what I was describing earlier sort of
the external Stakes of like what's the
consequence that will happen if your
character fails right that's usually in
a movie there's something external at
stake so life and death Stakes or like
somebody's safety or
um you know losing the house or what
have you but then there's also the sort
of internal Stakes of it the emotional
Stakes of it which is really like what
it means to your character so you know
it's important for the Adam Sandler
character to
um achieve that goal because of all that
stuff that it represents to him and
that's that I think is the more
emotional side of things and that's what
really gets us like emotionally invested
in a story you know
right I think there's like one scene in
the beginning or close to it where Adam
Sandler's on the phone with someone he's
like 50 year old guys don't have dreams
we have nightmares and panic attacks
yeah
yeah they do such a good job of like
layering that stuff in right of of just
exactly what does it mean if he fails to
you know get this last career thing
because it would be very easy for that
movie to sort of hit all of the the plot
beats that we expect but to feel empty
right like that would have been the bad
version of that movie of like you know a
near retirement guy has one last chance
to get a player signed and you could see
that playing out in a way that the plot
would make sense but because they went
the extra you know the extra mile in
terms of like developing that character
and what it all meant to him that made
it you know I loved that movie it made
it very emotional for me instead of just
being like oh this is a fun movie about
guys playing basketball it was much more
about the Adam Sandler character and
sort of you know that was like a
Redemption story for him it was like my
life hasn't been a waste I'm not too old
to accomplish things you know all of
those things I think were layered into
that movie and that's what made it
that's what actually I made it a movie
that I would recommend to people versus
one that I watch and forget about you
know and and then without giving away
too much the basketball player has his
own stakes and then you also see that
part of the stakes for Adam Sandler is
proving to the basketball player that
I'm I'm actually not going to let you
down yeah that's what was really great
about that movie too is that
relationship between those two guys so
it's very much an underdog sports movie
and the two of them are sort of the only
you know the only two the only person
that each has in their life that really
believes in them in a way that that sort
of matters and they can help each other
and so there are two underdogs sort of
working together to achieve this big
thing that nobody thinks they can
achieve so yes that that made me root
for them you know what I love that two
underdogs working together that's right
yeah yeah that's what works about it how
do we know the stakes are high enough
for the audience to be emotionally
invested that's a good it's a good
question and I think that's one of those
things that's a little bit
um you know trial and error in your in
your writing you do what you can to
um create the stakes in your story
external and internal
um try to plan them out in a way that
that you feel like will be enough to get
the audience invested but that is
definitely one of those things that you
know in completing the first draft
sometimes you have somebody read it
they're like I don't really understand
why this matters or I don't know know
why I should care about this story and
then you know that the stakes aren't
coming through right they may be high
enough but they may just not be conveyed
on the page in a way that the whoever
read it you know can understand why they
should care so there's both the aspect
of like
you know planning as you're developing
your story thinking through what's at
stake and why this is going to matter
and what it means to the character and
so that's why the audience will care
about it thinking through all of those
questions and and making sure that's in
your story that's half the battle and
then the other half is actually figuring
out how to put it on the page in a way
that your reader can pick it up right
and can understand and can feel sort of
what's at stake
yeah I think that was what was my
problem with bridesmaids when I heard
about it and it came out and everybody
was raving and I was turning on the
radio and oh Bryce and I'm like oh
another one of these female on female
hating each other and competing I don't
want to see that and it's it's not it's
so well done and there's you you really
see okay no this is there's a lot more
layers to this yeah and actually you
bring you bring up a good point because
seeing Helen come through in the end and
sort of change a little bit and seeing
that she and Annie don't end the movie
totally at odds with each other I think
that that was really important to to the
the sort of you know overall bigger
picture of that movie which was like
it's not about women competing against
each other it's actually about the
female friendship right and so even the
fact that the protagonist and antagonist
can come through the end of this
experience
learning enough about each other to kind
of not hate each other and not be
working against each other that was an
important lesson in the movie too can
you help us understand the difference
between the stakes for the protagonist
and the antagonist oh sure
um I mean I think each character
needs to have something at stake we
probably need to understand what's at
stake for the protagonist a little bit
more right because we're entering the
story through that character and their
experience of it is really what we're
sort of tracking and writing along with
through the entire movie
um so just in general I would say that
you know the protagonist Stakes are
probably going to be more developed
um both externally and internally we're
probably going to spend more time
understanding those Stakes
um establishing them in the movie and
then you know escalating them across the
movie but I do think that the antagonist
should have something at stake as well
otherwise
um I think that's when you get you know
kind of like I mentioned earlier you get
maybe one of those movies that hits
certain plot beats but feels a little
bit empty if we don't understand why the
antagonist is doing what they're doing
as well even if it's in very broad
Strokes you know
um I think it can feel
a little a little empty a little
cartoony or even a little bit sort of
like it doesn't have emotional logic you
know
sure
the movie The this at the book shop no
okay
yeah okay what was that one
um it was so good it was with Patricia
Clarkson who's like this sort of wealthy
woman who has started this art Society
in her town and then a new younger woman
comes in and opens up this bookstore and
that causes Patricia Clarkson standing
in the community like like who is this
and you're doing this in my town I'm
sorry and then the young woman starts to
put these beautiful book displays and
everybody comes in and they love their
books the bookstore and then she does
Lolita the book uh by navikov in the in
the um window and that's Patricia
Clarkson's in and you will not have this
in my town but really her her motive is
you won't show me up that that's really
what it's about and it's so well done
and
um it's it's about this sort of you see
each character's Stakes now one just
wants to do it because I forgot what the
reason was she needed something in her
life and this gave her joy and then the
Patricia Clarkson it was more about you
know her image and power and yeah the
two the two that uh well you bring up a
good point I haven't seen that movie I
will add it to my list but um but I
think you bring up a good point which is
you know when the conflict is more uh
character based or more sort of like
emotional rather than physical
um I think we probably need to develop
the stakes more right in order to
understand sort of why are these
characters in Conflict why are they
taking the actions that they're taking
whereas if you have something very
external very you know action-y or like
horror movies are often high stakes
they're they're life and death
situations but because it's such an
external physical uh conflict we
understand easily why this is important
right we understand it's a life and
death situation so you don't really have
to explain it as much or develop it as
much it's still useful I think if even
in movies that have very clear you know
external Stakes if you develop the
internal the the meaning of it as well
right because that helps us get sort of
more emotionally invested in the story
um but yeah the I think the story that
you brought up that Bookshop is a good
example of having
um you know the conflict is really it's
character based and it's um it's in not
internal but it's um it's not a physical
sort of conflict between the two of them
they have these like
big emotional Stakes for each of them
they're standing in the town or their
reputation or whatever and so you have
to develop those so that the audience
understands what's motivating them to do
the things they're doing because we
don't immediately understand
why someone would you know take those
actions that they're taking in the story
you know